- Last time that you were here,
you were just getting used to
living in Nashville, right?
So how do you, how do you love it?
- I need to take stock in Spanx.
(Kelly laughs)
I don't know how people live there-
- There's some great food.
- Yeah, same, Kelly.
- Girl, I lived there for 12 years.
- Kelly?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay, Hattie B's.
- Hot chicken.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Biscuit, love.
- [Kelly] Biscuits.
- The biscuits are like a crepe.
I don't know what.
And I've renamed-
You're gonna appreciate this.
- [Kelly] What?
I sat down and put my jeans on for today,
and I was like, "oh."
'Cause I've just come back.
The top on my jeans, like-
- Oh, the muffin top.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- So I think we should do this.
- [Kelly] I mean, I've heard of it.
- [Kristin] No-
- I don't have it.
(audience laughs)
- The muffin top!
- Just smooth sailing right here, but-
- Well, me too.
- Yeah.
- Because I'm Spanxed in.
(Kelly laughs)
- But, you've gotta rewrite the song,
and I think I know what it's gonna be.
Instead of "Rocky Talk"-
- [Kelly] Okay.
♪ Muffin top, you'll always be ♪
♪ Home sweet home to me ♪
♪ Good ol' muffin top ♪
- You're playing the arm!
(Kelly laughs)
♪ Muffin top Tennessee ♪
- I'm like, oh my, now I gotta be taped.
- I know, it's hard.
That's a hard place,
'cause there's so many great restaurants.
I mean like top notch chefs,
like, from, like, TV shows that have-
Oh my God, I think I'm forgetting one.
I'm gonna tell you in the break.
But it's an Indian one, and it's amazing.
Actually, I shouldn't tell
you, you're gonna get-
- Tell me, tell me.
- But it's so good. Anyway.
I have heard, though, speaking of food,
you're kind of classy and trashy.
So apparently you love 7-Eleven food.
- I do.
- [Kelly] All right.
- [Kelly] So is this just for,
like, road trip occasions,
or just like any day that ends in Y.
- It started out that way.
- Okay.
- And it evolved into,
- Mm-kay.
I'm kind of feeling like I need a snack
on the way to Kelly Clarkson,
so I'm gonna stop at 7-Eleven,
get a piece of pizza.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Their pizzas are great, y'all.
Also, their hot dogs.
They just turn 'em around.
You can get it however you want.
- I think, they're known for
their Slurpee machine, right?
- [Kristin] I love the-
- Yeah.
- I love the Slurpee.
- Yeah. Who doesn't?
- And I'm always mad when you
can't get the Coke to work.
And always, y'all notice that?
You go walk in, the Coke's broken.
- Y'all notice that?
(Kristin and Kelly laugh)
- It's, like, so southern?
- I know, totally.
But yeah, you get all kinds
of food, every snack you want.
You can get a light bulb,
you can get a piece of pizza.
(audience laughs)
You know?
- A light bulb?
- You get everything at 7-Eleven.
- [Kelly] You can, that's your bodega.
- [Kristin] I love it. And they said-
That is my bodega.
People are like, "what do you want?"
I'm like, "Coke Slurpee."
They're like, "Mm,"
We were thinking of more
like tea and crumpets."
I'm like, "no, not me."
(Kelly laughs)
I love it.
- Some days.
Yeah. But that's good.
- Yes, exactly.